you guys have such incredible chemistry
would you guys ever work together again
I would I would work with that man in a
second
he's guest a sweetheart he's and he does
so many good things and he's a crow and
you creates a great atmosphere on set
and he's so nice better
here's an idea because he's DC black
Adam now he's a superhero oh okay Nev I
think it's time for you to be a
superhero too
what do you think if you listen that I
in a second I would do that in a second
you would you okay so would your
superpower be course I would of course
there who would not but there aren't a
lot of those rules out there
unfortunately
what would your superpower be then what
would you want to take on it this is a
whole different conversation but yes I'd
love to be able to be invisible then I
won't have to throw your makeup and hair
in the morning Dwayne let's make it
happen
Plus NAB's already practicing her
superhero abilities by being a super mom
to her two kids at home you hear my kids
downstairs doing classes right now it is
a different world being in isolation how
are you coping as a muffler after a
whole month of being old my kids are
downstairs going to school as well well
one of the other ones not there yet you
know it's the same it's a very very
different world at the moment we're
trying to keep a positive attitude and
to say is diligence as we can and as
empathetic to others who are
experiencing a hard time as we can you
know and during these hard times some
provinces and US states are seeing an
increase in deaths linked to opioid use
which is the subject of nebs
heartbreaking and powerful new movie
hasil in the ground Oh doctor
why are you bringing in this party you
praying for your mother to get better
you don't have to worry baby I'm going
to be fine
get me a pageant I don't think it's a
good match now go to this jerk place was
it hard to let go of that once you went
home after shooting all day you know
going home
it must have taken a toll on you we knew
you're playing really this is important
Julie just trained shut it off put on a
comedy you get back to your room call
your kids call my husband trying have a
laugh how did you do the research you
talk to people who are dealing with it
did you do watch documentaries how did
you get into that world to understand it
even more yeah you know Joey had a lot
of knowledge about it his father is a
doctor in Montreal and has been helping
people with addiction for 30 years so I
had a lot of conversations with his
father actually and I watched a lot of
documentaries about the opiate crisis
that I'll be the addiction I you know I
have friends who have have dealt with
this kind of addiction as well so it's
close to home really yeah we all you
know it's it's pretty close to all of us
I think the danger is that we think it's
over there somewhere but it is so easy
you know I had spine surgery two years
ago like I get how if you're living with
name I mean and you can't deal with it
how easy it would be to just continue
you know and luckily I had a knowledge
about how addictive these fellows are so
I didn't come there